elles sont trois parties civiles deux
soeurs katia et laeticia et leurs demi
soeur sandrine unis dans ce procès elles
accusent leurs parents respectifs de
viol les faits se seraient déroulés dans
les années 90 aujourd'hui tout dit
attendre énormément de la justice on
veut qu'ils soient punis lourdement
voilà qu'on soit reconnue roffin enfin
qu'on sent reconnu victime de 2 to la
maltraitance des viols des insultes
l'humilie l'humiliation
je souhaite à personne de vivre ce que
j'veux qu'on a vécu pendant tout cas
tient accuse son père de s'être rendu
coupable de viols répétés survenu quand
elle avait à peine 13 ans sa demi soeur
sandrine l'accusent des mêmes faits à la
barre en larmes
laetitia elle parlera de cette famille
recomposée est installé dans l'yonne des
violences et insultes subi de
l'interdiction de se laver ou encore je
cite d'être obligé de faire les
poubelles pour manger est là qu sa
belle-mère de viols perpétrés sur les
trois jeunes filles lors d'un examen
gynécologique subi pour vérifier si elle
était vierge
de leur côté les avocats de la défense
n'ont pas souhaité s'exprimer devant
notre caméra
à ce stade du procès selon eux les deux
accusés nient les faits qui leur sont
reprochés il encourt l'un et l'autre
jusqu'à 20 ans de réclusion criminelle
les débats vont durer plusieurs jours la
cour d'assises pourrait rendre son
verdict vendredi